hi there just wanted to respond to some
of the comments on my latest rant about
kick-ass 2 and all this crop of movies
with the real-life people who become
cosplay vigilantes and why this trend is
pernicious first of all I want to call
out everyone who wrote in to compliment
me on how awesome I look in a luchador
mask I'd like to but none of you did
awesome saw as 30 rights thank god
someone came out and said that the only
movie like that that worked was mystery
man well thank you awesome saw as 30 but
let's be honest mystery men worked about
half the time sameo 15 the dragon tamer
right the point of these movies is it
every day normal people who don't have
powers or money or dramatic back stories
can be awesome too well of course they
do but in real life if real people are
committing real heroic acts they're
going to be wearing civilian clothes or
if they're wearing special costumes it's
going to be like a fireman's uniform or
surgical scrubs or suspenders with a lot
of flair I mean how do those waiters get
orders right with tables of like 15
people it's amazing cantu ej6 and ask
Leigh pious piranhas point out that
Batman doesn't have any special
abilities but he's a real superhero well
that's comic book reality I'm talking
about the real world in the real world
no billionaire has military intelligence
gathering equipment and vehicles and
personal weapons that would put the
Pentagon to shame except I don't know
Donald Trump Blanc otaku rights damn Rey
Mysterio put on weight how is he
supposed to do a Frankensteiner now okay
I get that reference and it's not
complimentary let me tell you I am a
menace in the ring my tag team partner
is gravity between the two of us we'll
do a number on you Rodney McKay rights I
disagree there is one man with
superpowers Ben Affleck with his powers
of persuasion
convince WB execs to cast him as you
know who ooh sick burn but Affleck was
the bomb in daredevil or no way
daredevil was the bomb or no daredevil
was a bomb Ben Affleck was in daredevil
and it was a bomb that's what I meant
thanks for watching keep on commenting
and subscribe to the wired channel so
you don't miss my full-length rant on
the casting of Ben Affleck as Batman
there's a lot of stuff I'm angry about
what's getting under your skin make a
video and let me know everyone's got an
angry nerd in them